You
I think I'm going to keep raising my vigor.
Yeah, the OSTs are great.
She be going ham.
She be is not going ham.
She be is just trying to get her bearings on the DLC.
Yeah, let me aggro you first.
I'm stuck.
This is just poop water.
Not resin.
It's not resin.
That's what I'm telling you right now.
How did that?
Look how much health he has.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Let me go and do flasks fairly quickly.
Well, I don't want to just simply run through anybody.
What is that?
Oh, that's good to see.
Discs of light.
OK, there's a well.
So I can either go through the well or I can.
Let me just take that.
Keep going down.
Are you guys coming some close to me?
Go away.
No, I don't like this.
Ah.
How do you guys have silver horn tender?
Interesting.
Sorry, you were just staring at me.
You were just minding your own business.
Interesting.
Why are you crying?
Mesmer fire.
Interesting.
That's not a door I can go through.
Do you want me to put you out of your misery?
I miss.
Wasted perfectly good stuff on that.
Why is this over here?
I'll die.
Well, I had a feeling I looked down the wall.
I thought I was going to be really fall.
That's why I didn't.
Oh, I probably shouldn't be standing here.
Yeah.
Great.
Here are the magicians.
Got to drink my milk.
That's some good milk.
All right.
Again, I know I can run past everyone,
but sometimes I just want to enjoy my song.
I want to explore, you know?
Hi, kitty.
Hi, baby kitty.
I'm like, now I have to actually play.
When it was just regular Elden Ring,
I knew what I was doing the entire time,
but now I want to sit and explore and do stuff and mess up.
Well, you're going to keep arguing me.
You're going to run over here.
Not that there's any rooms.
Let's just run past everyone.
I'm stuck.
What was I stuck on?
I was a dude sitting there.
What?
I'm being actually this, like, gang.
I think there was a dude sitting there,
and I was stuck on him when I tried to roll out.
Roll out.
No, don't say that.
That's terrible.
Stop it.
Get some help.
Maybe I should go down the well.
Ow.
How are they hitting me when I'm literally under the bridge?
No, no, no.
Why am I?
I'm getting stuck right here every time.
I don't want to have to kill you guys.
The lads on tour.
That's what's going on in this area.
Did she ever get the Twiggy cracked here?
No, I did not.
But I haven't really.
I've been using, like, buffing cracked tiers,
so I'm not too worried about the rooms.
Oh, yeah, they're all right here.
Oh.
Ow.
No.
Wow!
Is this where I just can't move forward at all?
Okay, I have to.
I guess I have to fight my way through.
This is stupid.
Thank you for the super stash power, by the way.
I didn't mean to do that.
All right, I'll run over here.
And I'll kill these two dudes.
Okay.
Can I stay in here until they still hit me?
Nope.
I can't hit them.
The glowing eyes on this one is funny.
Okay, so they shouldn't be able to hit me now,
and I can run up.
I'm just gonna grab this so I don't keep seeing it.
Oh my god.
No.
What the hell?
That's a stupid.
I keep getting, like, stuck in that, like,
that's one side for some reason.
The shadow people are not playing.
They're just, it's, they don't do,
they do, they do quite a bit of damage.
That's why I need to get that vigor up
and get the Scat of Tree Fragment.
Maybe I should get the Scat of Tree Fragment.
No, Raina, Raina, please.
You need to move.
It's who you attack it as a buff,
and you just let it keep runes upon death.
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
That's, I know, that's,
I've been saying I've been using stuff to buff
rather than stuff just to help.
Yes, I know that that means that.
They dropped the glowing.
Like, guys, I've played the game.
You don't have to tell me I have played the game.
Raina, my darling, I'm so sorry, but you need to move.
I can't have two cats, three cats on my desk.
I need something, I need to use my...
Okay.
Ow.
Why do they have such a long range?
Really, I'm not...
Yeah.
It's a really cool, I'm assuming that's an incantation
because it seems like holy...
Oh.
Why does that have such a long range?
It's still hitting me.
It's still going to hit me.
I'm so sorry, gentlemen.
Jesus Christ, I hate this.
Oh my God.
I've played the game before.
It doesn't mean that I'm good at it.
I haven't played the DLC, though.
Guys, this might take a bit.
Just telling you.
Might just take just a little bit.
Why am I...
Oh my God.
Ah!
Oh, a Knight Comet.
What about Magical Blade?
It doesn't matter.
Or a Rocksling.
I didn't do anything.
I really should just sit back down.
I don't know why.
Okay, thank you guys.
You guys all had to go through it too.
Sorry.
Comet is effective, but the FP cost is just high.
I think I might kind of just use...
I'm going to use it only on the two dudes up top.
Comet is pushing into sleep, and it's funny.
You need to wait for him to come over.
Come here.
You're walking mighty slow.
Are you going to lunge forward there, bud?
There you are.
How do you have any health left?
That's my question.
Boomi, it's just rain.
Rain is playing in the tunnel, and Boomi set up so fast
because you're the jingling.
Sara, I need you to lay back down with your pouch.
He just did a big stretch.
My cats are thwarting me.
Good boy, Boomi.
Oh, perfect.
Thank you.
He just laid down.
I can't cast fast enough.
Why is it locking on him?
Oh, my God.
It's fucking me up.
Raina, are you okay?
She's playing with her ball in the tunnels.
It's like a tri-tunnel.
Good night.
Have a good night.
I'm going to wait for them to walk over here, actually.
Sara drew him.
Yeah, bud.
Oh, God.
You are mighty annoying up there.
No, this is not happening again.
Are you serious?
Guys, guys, I thought they were gone.
I thought I got every one of them
missing up the dude in the corner,
but there was another one.
Boomi was waiting indeed.
No.
Sit down, sit down, sit down, sit down, sit down.
It's cool that there's a grace right here.
That's interesting.
What are you doing?
How did you aggro me?
That's so crazy.
I literally...
What?
Make that make any sort of sense.
How did he just ran in?
Did he hear me?
I don't understand.
What are you doing?
The DLC, I think, for anything.
It would just have to be nicer.
I'm just going to sit back down to be honest with you.
I kind of want to PB&J.
Sir, Boomi, can you lay down?
I can't see past your giant.
He just laid on my go XR and muted me.
Oh, thank you for the 10 gifted.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Boomi just closed my game.
And opened up Microsoft 365 for some reason.
Everybody say thank you, Boomi.
Stop.
Oh, God.
Let me sit back down again.
Okay.
I'm honestly debating if I should just run around.
Do they scale with the...
With the Scattertree?
I thought you were dead.
Do they scale with the Scattertree stuff?
The bosses?
They don't?
Then I'm wondering if I should go and run around and collect more.
I might do just that.
Only new game cycles? Okay.
Oh, you look like a very strong motherfucker.
Oh.
I kind of want your swords.
Ow.
Can I have your swords?
No?
That's rude.
Which way, Western Man?
Am I in the ruins of King's Landing?
What is this?
Oh.
Not the Piss River.
Were you trying to sneak up on me, brother?
It's not very cash money of you.
Then Beast Bones.
Okay.
Are we sitting on something?
I don't know.
Okay.
I need one Scattertree fragment so I can do them in one hit.
Because that's annoying that I have to do two hits.
Wait, that's where I came from.
Yes, God, you're blessing, yeah.
Oh, that was the first time I swore.
I swore, I think.
That's why it's saying, like, hell.
Oh, here we go.
Yep.
I don't know.
I know, I saw that too.
I saw the scale with Faith, but I read that before I read the other message.
Did we meet the boss here yet?
No.
I literally just got here.
Ow.
Actually, can you kill me because that was just annoying.
Actually, no.
Let me grab them and then you can kill me.
Yeah, dominate the boss, sure.
I know already, is this the dancing lion thingy?
I already know how trash I'm going to be with that.
Excuse me.
Reena?
Oh, frick.
Booby's head is in the way.
Oh, now he's laying down on my go XLR, so now I can see.
He, like, ran off trying to get away from him because I couldn't see.
I think this is running simulator.
Oh, wow.
Strange.
Damn.
I need to work on my freaking poise if this is what happens.
What are those?
Yeah, I beat everything first try.
100%.
Okay, I must have to go.
Nothing.
How did he follow me over here?
Danny, good job.
Okay.
That just went right up my booty hole.
Damn, that standing up animation took me forever.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Who is that?
Fire Knight.
Where are you at, though?
Oh, I missed some so did you.
Okay.
No, I didn't mean to do that.
I meant to do the thrilling turn.
Okay.
Can we come over here?
That's a cool blade.
That's a cool name.
That's a reach on it.
Why are you named freaking Queen Lynn?
You look like Prince freaking Charming.
Really? I've actually never seen this NPC.
I don't know about them.
I might have just to run away from it.
What?
I don't know what just happened there.
That was odd.
I must have fallen and then I didn't see how.
I might just ignore it.
I don't know what just happened there.
That was odd.
I must have fallen and then I didn't see how.
I might just ignore him
and run around.
Oh, he must be one of Mesmer's little girly pops.
It's open.
No, he's open.
I'm assuming I have to do something about him.
How do I get out of this area and progress?
Do I have to beat him to progress?
What just faces over here?
I feel like I should be able to do some sort of parkour.
What?
Okay.
Excuse me.
I have the high ground Anakin.
Well, this doesn't lead anywhere.
Okay.
Is there someone compared?
Do I just kill him?
Yeah, okay.
But do I need to kill him to progress?
That's my question.
Okay.
Okay, so where do...
I don't know where to go from here.
The poopy water is where I need to go.
Huh.
I'll ignore him for now then.
Oh, I keep almost falling off.
How did he...
Oh, oh my.
I didn't think he would follow me all the way over there.
I'm kind of confused.
Is there... there must be a thing to the side of the mess?
Okay.
His weapon is pretty cool.
It has really cool reach.
Because I don't... I can't go through here.
I keep getting stuck.
These guys trap you.
Like there's...
You can't do anything.
No, I don't need to know, but thank you.
Okay, he just told me anyways, but thanks.
Okay.
Oh.
He's gonna kill me.
I didn't see the door the other way before.
They're not even tough, they just are annoying at this point.
I killed them in only a couple hits, so...
I just need more vigor.
I feel like vigor doesn't really mean a lot.
I feel like if mine was across the screen, I still wouldn't even matter.
It's already halfway there.
I'm gonna go through.
Don't you dare hit me down.
Oh my god.
He can... what?
You can climb ladders?
Since when? Since when?
Since when I'm gonna fall off.
Get out of the way.
I didn't even mean to do that.
Oh my god. Fuck off.
Oh my god, actually.
That's not fair.
I don't like that at all.
We shouldn't be able to climb.
Alright, where are you then?
Avastji.
Okay, so this is the other side.
Wow, throwing daggers is what I've always wanted.
I feel like you can parkour.
I hear roaring.
Interesting. Well, obviously I've walked through there, so I'm not going to do that.
I'll try to attempt to jump it.
He was crying.
Wait, I thought I could...
From the angle, it looked like it was a thing I could walk on.
How am I supposed to get over there?
Okay, it's the other side then.
You're not.
What are you doing here?
Oh, I didn't see you there.
Very interesting.
I don't see...
I think something would be up in that little tower there, but there isn't.
The color is standing funny.
Oh my god, this is so huge.
I'm like, quite overwhelmed.
Just like how I was when I first played Elden Ring.
It's a very unique feeling.
Where are y'all coming from?
This would be good to have a crowd control stone.
Oh, what? I just totally missed.
I mean crowd control, I didn't even spell.
Scorpion liver?
Sombra smithing stone.
Are there more coming?
What the hell is that noise?
Oh, it's...
What are those?
Oh, it's like fly thingies.
I'm going to keep moving this way for now.
I'm moving this way for now.
Although this looks like a freaking boss room for no reason.
Something going to fall?
Oh, yeah, there you are.
Oh, there's one first.
I think I'm out here.
Come back.
Oh, they really stagger you.
Oh, there's more in the door.
Yeah, the DLC is fun.
Exploring stuff, I haven't really gone that far.
I apologize for the lack of speaking.
I'm very sleepy in my headache and stuff.
So I'm just chilling.
I think that cliff thing is there for a reason.
So you can lift up and jump off of it.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Please kill the spawn.
Kill them all.
A scorpion vtuber would be very cool.
More invertible.
It's weird that scorpions are rocklings.
So there's the first one.
Oh, it's right there.
There's another one right there.
Why does that one look like it spits fire or something?
Because it has like a red body versus a black body.
Very interesting.
There must be different types then.
Yeah.
Maybe it's gender dimorphism.
It looks a lot different.
It has like a skinnier body.
Or maybe I'm looking at the wrong thing.
No, it is definitely different.
Interesting.
Are you going to come attack me?
I knew you were going to clip through the wall.
Interesting.
I wonder what this one does.
Okay.
You're a lot weaker.
To my pants.
I don't know what that status is.
I can't tell if it's poison or not.
Bonebow.
Okay.
Yeah, it looks like poison,
but I can't remember because I haven't...
Oh.
These don't go anywhere.
Oh, is there nothing in here
just as ominous and scary?
All right.
Yeah, second try.
Maybe...
as if they're bosses.
Is this lead somewhere? Is this where it came from?
Yeah.
I don't like the chittering of those
fly things.
Let's go this way.
There's also the well I can always go to.
The bird is just burdened.
I'm so angry.
I'm just hanging out.
I'm also missing you.
Am I just stunning you?
It's not very natural,
but that's fine.
I am just too short.
Imagine if you could lift yourself up in this game.
That'd be crazy.
Oh, I'm gonna be right here.
Oh yeah, I forgot you under there.
Oh.
Dragonfly thing.
So creepy looking.
Oh, you can fly?
Easter.
I maxed out my thingy.
Same, bro.
Wow.
Me when I do.
Ew, look at the maggots.
You see that? That's crazy.
Very nice touch
to change up the poison.
Why am I not hitting right over here?
What?
Can I please back up?
Oh my god, you're...
I'm trying to heal.
Can I...?
It's like not looking down to the right person for some reason.
There's been a lot of that today.
Oh, okay, the poopoo water does not do anything to me.
I couldn't tell if it was poison water or not,
but I guess poison's a little bit...
greener.
Yeah, there seem like there are a lot of paths.
Yeah, that's a...
I'll be like, that was me.
So me.
This is the latest poop water.
Okay, who's gonna try to grab me?
There you are.
What are you doing?
You're aggroing the little thing, dude.
I don't have to do that.
Someone hit the pot, just because.
Bro.
Yeah, I peed quite easily.
What does it mean I have a...
I don't have much of a drag reflex though.
It's one of those guys, baby.
And my blue upside stream.
I kind of want to do one of those sooner.
Because I kind of just want to play who I pop.
Oh, I didn't see how low my health was or what it healed.
I'm very excited to get the other tools.
All right.
This is a lot of running.
Not that I can't just run past everybody, but...
Mm-hmm.
We have to, like, try not getting hit.
And then we have to try not getting hit on the ladder.
I knew you were there.
I didn't know you were going to do that to me, though.
What?
Pfft.
It's okay.
We're having a chill stream.
I'm trying to use the white one.
I don't know why it's like...
No, bro.
Hang on.
I should have picked those up.
Was it painted into my health again?
I'm tired of running all this way.
I'm going to take the fattest nap after this stream.
I realize, like, I will sleep,
but I won't sleep sleep.
Like, I went to bed after I streamed,
which was, what, like 12?
And I woke up at, like, 8,
and I still feel like I didn't sleep at all.
Bumi is touching something on my keyboard,
and it's kind of...
messing me up.
I don't know what he's on.
It's okay.
I just really scared him.
There's just one keyboard.
What?
Why can't I climb?
That was weird.
Yeah.
Well, I'm sleeping on the couch
to be closer to her.
I should have really just
bring her to my bed with me.
Where am I now?
Hi.
No.
No, I wanted to go look at stuff
and you ruined it.
Dang, moving through this is annoying
because I just die in a couple of hits.
I need, like, a wrap around.
There's just like, the grace is so far.
It's really just running to get there
that's annoying.
Because I finally got there and then I die
because I'm like, oh, what's this?
Oh, what's over here?
And then I die to something I don't know that's nearby.
Like, this guy just took me to half.
And I feel like he shouldn't be able to.
Do you want to hit?
No, I'm fine.
I didn't have to heal, but whatever.
Doesn't really matter.
I'm probably going to die soon anyways.
Are you serious?
I'm not sure about that.
I'm not a fan of that.
They do.
They really do.
I just want to progress.
That's all I want to do.
Yeah, that's like, I am my poise.
It's trash for some reason.
I can't wait to get another armor set here.
Oh, my God.
Please climb the ladder.
I really should just kill that guy
any time I run past him.
Hopefully I don't get stun locked
when I come off the ladder.
That would be great.
That would be lovely.
Can I go up this side?
I can.
Can I?
What is that?
Run past your stupid ass.
No.
Where are you holding?
I don't know what that is.
I'm going to die.
That's how it ends.
With a black pyre fry in hand.
No.
I should have died to that.
All right, stay down there, please.
I got stuff to do.
I got people to see.
Okay, that's stupid.
Stop.
What?
No.
Ow.
What?
No.
Oh, you motherfucker, bro.
You motherfucker.
Sorry, I'm trying to look around.
Oh, they're the state of America.
Thank fucking God.
Jeez.
Pot carrier.
Oh, okay.
The camera angle.
Interesting.
What is that?
Okay.
I don't have that good of poise, though.
So I'm skeptical about playing soccer.
I might go kill that pot carrier, then,
or at least attempt to.
Since the stake is right there.
Okay.
Oh, my God, please.
What was that?
What?
I'm like, please, please just let me, please just let me pick it up.
I didn't know if Sifu was a challenging game.
Not that I played it.
I've seen it before, but I never...
What? I can't go to the stake.
Did I accidentally do whatever?
I couldn't be near the stake America?
That's dumb.
Let's just do this fucking shit again.
You can just hit me on the way up.
You dare knock me off?
I swear to God.
That too far? Yeah.
At least I know I can come over here
and I can hop up the other way.
Why are you so on me?
To avoid this one here.
You think you could fly up here, but you can't.
You're stupid.
It's not letting me do my actual war.
I don't...
I'm so weird.
What?
Where the...
What did he come from?
I sound like Icy for a second today.
You'll think I sound like Icy.
I don't know where he came from, genuinely.
Around each corner there is a dude.
Just a dude.
Oh no, I shouldn't have attacked him.
No.
I will not allow it.
Did he climb that and then follow me all the way over here?
I just want to know.
Why did...
Was I auto walking on?
I don't like how human their noises are.
Haha.
He's already up there.
I didn't... Is there... Oh yeah, he's over that side. That's what it was.
I like the song in this area.
It's very cool.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
What is that?
I didn't even get to see what it was, but it reminded me of Malky.
What is that? I can't even tell.
What are you?
Oh, you have the same moveset as the fucking dragon.
Alright, lion. It looks like it.
Ooh, cool looking.
I feel like I would have done the wrong side of grace, so I'm sorry.
I don't know why.
He is a quicky little boy.
Let's see.
He doesn't do too much damage.
I don't know.
I can summon Freo.
Let's go say hello.
Wreck the Boss? That's not happening.
Who's talking?
What?
It's a big bag of food.
Rice.
So this is dead body, just chilling here.
Then I just resurrected it.
Grandma?
Who's grandma?
Is that the lady who talked?
I don't know.
Yes, I know.
Like, I can't remember.
That's a foot.
That's so cool.
I never knew that it was like...
It has human body parts under there.
I thought it was like an actual giant lion, but it's very heavily inspired by an actual dancing lion.
That's so cool.
Divine Beast.
What is this song?
Beast Face.
What kind of music do you hear?
I don't know.
Okay.
Oh, yes.
It's very hard to see.
It does so much.
It's very hard to read its patterns.
It's smart that they put the grace right next to the door.
This could be a Bloodstone Blade sort of thing.
So this thing will kill me in two hits, that's for sure.
Yeah.
Because of the Dodge AI, I would probably want to do the Bloodblade, I mean.
Yeah, the theme is really cool.
I know who Wukong is, but I don't know what you mean.
What's that from?
I might call it England.
Oh, true, because it's invisible.
Let's see, let's see.
Let's see two little ashes.
Is that worth your time?
I guess I pressed it too slow.
I don't know if it hitboxed those because I thought it was pretty far away.
Oh, it's a game.
Oh, interesting.
The column block meant interesting.
I didn't haven't heard about that.
What?
That thing pulled me and almost got me in one hit.
Yeah.
Really beautiful music.
It's so hard to read this, and I wonder why it's one of the hardest bosses.
Yeah.
I would need skill to kill this one, which I do not have.
Can I?
My poise is so bad.
I don't...
I just keep getting stomached.
I don't understand.
Why do I...
I just...
Yeah, it kills me in two hits.
And I'm not...
That would mean I would have to avoid getting hit.
And I don't know enough of a boss to do that.
It's happening out of the fucking way.
I don't like that it opened with that one.
I'm so confused because it looks like it hits me when it...
I don't react to it sometimes.
My character doesn't respond, and I don't notice.
Yeah, I need to get better armor.
If you have any recommendations, let me know.
Just tell me where to get it.
Don't tell me what it is.
Can you aggro the mimic tier, please?
I don't...
Oh, my God.
I want to take a picture, but I would get my phone and it would wake him up because he's very adorable.
Yeah, the boss is not even acknowledging the mimic.
Why do you...
I don't like it when you open with this hit because then you somehow clean it and pick it up.
And I also can't tell the timing because I can't tell when it hits me or not.
I never react to that front hit for some reason.
Can you get a lead on this?
I need backup.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, now you have lightning? That's just not fair.
I can't quite tell what's happening.
Oh, but...
I can't understand what's happening.
Oh, wow.
I didn't think I would get that for.
Okay, alright.
I didn't notice that I could repost him. I didn't hear it.
I only realized after the fact that he was stunned.
Okay, I might have this.
He's not as scary as I thought.
Okay, he didn't open with that one.
I need to get that lead up. Oh, shit. I didn't even know that I died already.
Again, it's hard to tell when I'm hit because the character doesn't audibly react.
It's very hard to see the...
You know how sometimes a hit animation is there?
Unless I'm staggered, it's hard to tell.
That's fine. I'm just stuck in the corner. Don't worry about it.
It's just a bunch of dudes. Just a bunch of dudes under there.
I could take on a bunch of dudes.
Don't you? That sounds terrible, actually. Oh my god, Jesus Christ.
No, I like this boss. The boss is very cool.
Okay.
Why? I'm genuinely surprised that it's not aggroing the Mimic tier.
The grandma breath attack. I think you just have to jump into it.
Oh, just be like that. It seems like it. I thought I could roll over it,
but it seems it's better just to jump over it.
Okay.
He's just very into me.
I'm not even making sure I go over it, because I'm just making sure he's aggroed on him.
No, he's gonna be over me.
Oh, because in the second phase, it was easier because he was aggroed on the Mimic,
and that's why he didn't pay attention to me as much. That's why I was closer. Bye. Have a good one.
Two horns in the trench coat. That's funny.
Oh my god, Bumi is so cute. Oh my god, I gotta pet him.
Handsome boy, why are you so adorable? Oh, you're stretching your little toes.
Oh, baby boy. Bumi, why are you so precious right now?
Hey, how about that one?
I'm stuck in him. What is happening?
That was weird.
What?
Why am I not doing my actual goal?
Oh my god.
Why are you searching so long?
Holy shit.
What the hell? How did it only take me like five tries?
That's so crazy. Thank you, Mimic tier.
I thought this was going to take me hours.
You guys are lying. Shut up.
What the hell? How did I... guys, what?
Oh my god, that's fun.
This is the first boss. He's not bad in comparison to the rest.
Someone's like, he's not that bad. Don't worry about it. Don't let it get to your head.
Okay, actually, I don't really need anything there.
That's the...
Makes my focus zero.
I can't see anything past this. What?
This is so huge.
I could go get Lionel's set.
Just to kill feet? No, wait.
I forgot I already have it.
But then I have a heavy load.
I feel like a regular hat.
But then my poise goes to 61.
That's so bad.
They call me Mr. Bombastic. Very fantastic.
I like them big.
Hold on, I have to move my cat because he's in the water and I can't give you the hot girl wrench.
How are you doing, Ms. Mom?
I got a bunch of buttons on my keyboard.
I am Mr. Bombastic right now.
I am the Elden Mord.
Take a pic, it's me.
Biggie cheese.
Okay, so now what do I do?
Guys, I thought that was going to take me a lot longer.
Is there a way to go straight out of there?
No, there's no doors.
Don't worry, I'm smart.
Biggie Biggs, they call me Shibby Shibs.
Mr. Lava Lava.
Hi, Boomi.
Time to get trolled by the game.
And we're back at the beginning.
Wait, where am I?
I'm doing what physics said, go back to the beginning.
Am I going to get hit by a ball?
Something is going to happen over here, I just know it.
Dry leaf? No, but I found fly leaf.
I can feel you all around me.
Think I need the air high breathing.
Sorry, hold on, I need to put on my...
Oh tower of ours hidden in shadow.
Oh lofty spiral piercing the heavens.
Lead him safely onto greater godhood.
And in divinity grant our salvation.
I'm probably going to use that effect during the ASMR tomorrow.
Actually, no, I wouldn't be able to.
Actually, no, I could put reverb and echo on my...
I'll just have to use plug-in for that instead of my mixer.
Because it'll be the tower of shadow message.
It'll be excuse me, lemme in.
Since it's a non-one and it's a non-role play, I'm going to be in a chapel.
Sealing obscured by shadow.
Well, I'm killing myself.
Wise men should fear three things.
A sea at storm, a night with twin moons.
And the anger of a gentle bunny.
I thought it was a night with no stars.
Anger of a gentle man.
Doors of stone, please, I'm begging you, Patrick Roffus.
You know what I'm going to use my platform for?
I'm going to use it to beg Patrick Roffus, me, a bunny girl,
Dominatrix bunny girl, to beg Patrick Roffus to release Doors of Stone.
In the game, right?
Yeah, never underestimate a rabbit.
It's pointing out of something that way.
I feel like there should be a door over here. Why would they have stairs?
Stupid. Let me out.
All right.
I could go to the well, so I'll do that.
Didn't mean to press that. Hold on.
My hint is the funny emote.
Because I didn't go over here.
I guess I'll go over here.
I need a key for the well. I have a storehouse key.
I'm examining. I'm examining using X.
Okay, it's square.
Message left by needle knight Leda.
Address the kindred spirit to pursue Mykola's trail.
They gated divinity lies in a tower sealed by shadow.
That is surely where the kind Mykola is headed.
We are no imperians.
We must locate the path that will lead us there.
I will follow the crosses east.
Okay.
There's a lot of castles to go through, which is interesting.
Where's the well?
Well, well, well.
It's over here, right?
Yeah.
Later, bitch.
Boomi.
He's just curling up all cutely on my mousepad.
I have two.
That's the key to grandma.
Okay, we'll figure it out.
What we know.
So these are you right there and you guys right there.
I'm going to go after you first.
I'm assuming this is the...
Okay, yeah.
So I can't go down this way, but I'll grab what's down here at least.
Mesma fire.
Can I...
Can I please climb?
My outfit is on peak.
I am actually getting it.
Where?
I did. Thank you.
Excuse me.
Just got to go this way.
Is there another...
I feel like there's another avenue that I have not gone.
Like I never went down the stairs.
This is where I came up from.
But I never went down the stairs near the bug.
Can't kill the prince charming.
Oh, thank you for stopping by.
Where's grandma?
What is grandma that you speak of?
Whoa, bro.
Oh.
Freaking chucked me.
Grandma is left to the second grace.
Hold on.
I need to pause and think.
Did I go down there?
I think I did.
Oh, that's where this dude is.
Oh, he will give more runes if I kill him.
Maybe I shall.
Or maybe I shan't.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Later, later, alligator.
See you soon, you masturbator.
What?
Climb, you fools.
Wait, I should probably level up the...
Who's aggroed on me?
Really? Okay.
I got my head just...
I'm sick, sick, sick.
I like them big.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
One of my co-workers would say that to me.
My last job when I would get hit on by someone.
They'd be like, oh, I think Motomoto likes you.
What's down here?
Oh.
Babies, move. Babies, move.
Babies, move.
Please, babies.
Babies, babies.
Babies.
Kill.
I'm being chased by children.
Kill the children.
In Minecraft.
Being accosted by a child.
I missed.
Okay, I got...
I like how it flips over.
Okay.
Uh, this one?
Was it this grace?
Oh, is where I beat the lion dancer.
Okay, let me just hop up here then.
It sounded like Anakin.
Yeah, I only have...
I don't have any...
I think I have one fragment.
Okay, it's too...
Is it to the right?
Of her?
Okay, so she's down here.
She's over here somewhere, grandma.
I genuinely cannot believe it only took me, like,
a handful of tries.
I...
Amazing boss, though.
I love the boss.
But again, I used the mimic, so...
Although I used it just to really get Diagro off me.
Hi, Tomah!
Nowhere I was getting beaten to death by the horde.
What?
You like the helmet that you get?
Oh, it's so funny.
The jaw is clipping through the armor.
I'm gonna need that mimic, yeah.
Damn, would we make it heavy?
I don't know.
So that would change that.
I could do the exile free.
The damage negation isn't as high.
I could put on some of my finger maiden shoes.
A playful game.
That would be cool.
Alright, how do I get to this lady?
I'm not cute, I'm handsome.
Pinch is your cheek, oo-woo.
You're just a cute little guy.
Oh, I thought that was somebody standing behind that.
Alright.
Can I hope down?
Am I gonna die?
Oh!
I didn't mean to do that.
I thought I could drop down to the ledge.
I suppose not.
Whoopsie-daisies, no worries.
At least it's not far.
Oh, okay, I like the spiral introduction.
I realize I have like a three musketeers freaking thingy.
I'm off to see the grandma, the wonderful grandma of Oz.
Wonderful grandma of Lance between.
Wonderful grandma of LBs.
Wait.
Okay.
I was like, wait, where was I on the stairs?
So I can grab these little runey rooms.
The spiral motif.
It's all about the horn scent and what they believe in.
The idea of the spiral is very, very interesting.
Very holy thing.
Reaching towards the heavens.
Oh, what's this then?
What's this then?
There's something on the other side.
These shadowy branches are hiding something.
Or maybe they're fucking not. Hello?
Stairway to heaven reference.
Guys, I thought you said I'd go to the right or the left.
Izumaki all over again.
At the second grade.
What second grade?
Which one?
You said this one?
And you said this one?
Oh, okay.
Let me see here.
Small private altar.
Yes, I've read all of Junji Ito's works.
That's...
Okay.
Now where do I go?
Tell me the where.
Is it this way?
It is indeed this way.
Who is jorking their peanuts right now?
You are not looking so well horn sent.
I need some of you guys to record something like this for me.
I watch my stuff be limited because of this.
Where the hat?
How about now?
Hello?
Are you with two fingers?
Does it keep her stand before me?
She's like a finger lady.
At least it's the same model because it literally looks like her added stuff.
Like how I'm just staring him in the face.
Can I see my face?
No, I cannot.
Like cholera?
I don't know. Mesmer didn't really deserve any of this.
I blame his mom to be honest.
The family is messed up.
Just desserts.
Song?
That's your son is a watchful spirit?
Or dude.
Thanks I guess.
If I take this off will you be like traumatized?
I'm going to dance in cavort.
Oh I could have just grabbed this.
I could have just stolen this.
Can't break any of these.
You didn't care about those pots did you?
I hope not.
It's all the horn sent and the America's fault.
Wait.
What?
Is this grandma?
Oh somebody said him so I don't know if it's the same person.
Can I leave?
Cool beans.
Can't get over there yet.
Oh my god lady shut up.
I guess we'll go through here.
At the castle front.
Thank you.
I think I might make myself a PB&J.
Hello?
I'm the juggernaut bitch.
Castle ensus.
Oh you have a giant carrion sword.
My stuff is probably going to be totally non-resistant to you.
Yep.
That sounds about right.
Break out locking on you.
I need a different weapon.
This is going to be something to do against them.
I need another weapon to level up.
Why is there nowhere to go?
Extra stream great fighting for voice.
I have a good time at work.
Hi hi welcome in.
Yeah what?
Yeah it seems like I am in a bit of a conundrum here.
Let's not go here yet then.
Because if they're going to be magic based people then...
I'm not going to have the best time.
Oh my god if you fall off that would be kind of incredible.
Can you?
No, damn it.
I was hoping I could knock you off.
Oh.
I'm also trying to figure out the way inside.
Oh I think I go around him.
I'm not straightforward.
Yeah okay so I'll get past them then.
I have a feeling.
Maybe I should just keep going until I get it.
Hit me.
Yeah why don't you go over there buddy?
Alright.
How long are you going to chase me for?
Is there a grace over here?
That would be great.
Oh my god is he still here? Holy crap.
I'm scared. Oh no I'm scared.
Oh and this?
The runner?
I just hear the giant walking around so it's freaking me out.
Time for the funny sword.
Assuming there's a sword up here.
Might I just get teleported somewhere?
If I just get teleported to Caled I would actually lose my mind.
Milady?
What the heck type of sword is it?
It's a light? A light great sword?
How does that happen?
Oh.
Yeah I meant it when I said I climb you like a tree.
How did I get out of the town?
I better if I jump down I'm going to die.
I'm fine.
I speak for the trees.
Oh someone's missing stone.
It's a sturdy tree because I'm a thick boy.
Is he? He's not aggro.
I was hoping there wasn't a side of Grace nearby that I could just sneak around him for.
Okay so I got that.
Hold on let me switch back to my actual up in the nose using before.
Okay that's that over there.
Whoa what's all the way up there?
Wait a second.
Is there something above this?
Oh wait no that was just there. Holy crap.
Was I?
I don't know. I don't think so.
I think it's a different area.
I think that's passed over here.
Yeah it is. Isn't it?
Every player's nightmare is up there.
Oh man.
Can't wait.
How am I?
Stop showing me things that I can't get to yet.
It's annoying.
Something gonna fall and attack me? No.
I'm just looking around every corner.
Who's in here? Is it a dude? No?
Royal Knights cookbook.
Magic Grace. Royal Magic Grace.
Coat's armament.
Oh wait no I read that as armor.
Cool.
I don't have any pots.
Man flowers.
Hefty Fireball.
Crystal Blood Pot.
Grace me up baby.
Oh where the hell did you come from?
I don't know what to use on here.
Holy guacamole.
Oh my.
That was surprising.
What?
All right.
All right, all right, all right.
Okay no ladies.
Yeah.
I said what's cooler than being cool?
I just couldn't.
I can't hear you.
I said what's being cool?
What's cooler than being cool?
I just couldn't.
It's harder because it's dark out.
Can you get your dog off me?
He's still following me.
Is your owner still following me too?
Oh he just eventually walked over here as a thing.
No I don't want to run all the way back up there.
It's okay.
It looks like I can use Moonvale over here.
This is good if I don't want to use Meal though.
Guys are pretty easy to backstab.
Oh okay.
They usually are.
Usually like those knights are able to backstab.
This troll just follows me all the way up.
I remember I was watching a thing as this like beating Elden Ring when every boss is constantly aggro and there's no aggro limit.
They'll follow you anywhere.
It's like the snail.
I'm sorry puppy I'm busy.
That's it.
You're a hundred percenting but uh bloodborne. That's cool. I want to play bloodborne. I've never played bloodborne
What are these doing over here? Oh, is there another one? Oh, I got helpful
Do I have enough now
Yay
Oh
But wait, what are you? Hello, what are you doing here?
Why do I hear someone like running up? Okay, I'm not gonna hop down there yet. I want to kill this guy
See if he drops anything good, although I know he's not like
Oh, I thought I dodged that
Thought I dodged that as well, but I was a second too late
You a hundred percented Sekiro, what is wrong with you? How do you know how do you do that? That's wild to me
I
Missed I
Died to the shocky ground
You
I
I've been talking this whole time Bumi just muted me. I'm so sorry
Let me put his paw his back paw on my go XLR. I hope I haven't been how long have I been quiet for cuz that's annoying
I
My god, please
I meant to press B no
This is a boomy train that silenced me
Just want to kill him I'm dying to him faster than the the dancing beast
What I like I it's like when I stood up I was still in the hitbox or something
For me don't
He just muted me again
Big me and all you look so tired
Just for you because I gave Fia your old one
I
Can't break his poise. I don't know why I'm trying to
That's a good point and I can't really see that well past boomy cuz he's taking up probably a fourth or a third of my screen
This night and another story
Sometimes I'm also very sleepy, so I'm not really trying hard
Like I should be
I
What what come on why am I playing so bad?
Camera is harder he is smoking me
How much of a do this
Move your freaking shield
I
Wish I had the ambush that would have been nice
I was stunned and I couldn't roll out of the wall
No, I don't think so I want to kill him
Yeah
I was I've been trying to roll behind him and backstab him again
Oh
I didn't think he was gonna do it three times
It's hard to roll around him cuz he like
Sometimes they just lock on and they just move on there like they just pivot
With what doesn't make any sense. They just like spin around
While doing their thing and it's funny because you can't do that as a player boomy when are you doing?
He just turned around as easily know my desk
And he's now he's watching my screen and grooming himself. No boomy. I can't see past you
Boomy is now taking up half of my screen. I'm going to fight with one half of my screen
No, I blame you so hard. I can't see can't backstab
It's safe. Oh
No boomy just laid on my no boomy boomy boomy boomy please boomy please boomy please boomy no
He laid on my windows key and tapped out my game
No, no, no, he's also laying on my mouse. He's using my mouse as a pillow
You silly little boy. Yeah, that one doesn't count boomy interference. Sorry, I'm just
Yeah
Okay, get behind you
Oh
How does that hurt me so bad
Cap challenge in my handicapped as my cat is just constantly in front of my screen
Can I summon this man needs to die in Elden Ring I
Still really close to him
I
Was stuck no
No, no, no, I'm sorry now. I'm like determined to kill him even though I know he'll come back. I just want to kill him
Black Knight hammer guy
It iron table on my head you shouldn't be able to kill me in two hits. He's not a boss
He doesn't deserve that sort of power I'm going to take it from him
Why don't you get down there so I can
I
Like how his body doesn't move he like he doesn't look like he runs forward
He just looks like he pushes his arm like a mile away from him
Damn he got hands it is really a vigor shack
My name is in Hugo Montoya you killed my father be back to die
Oh
I'm almost dead
I
Die
Yay
What?
Jesus Christ. How are you still alive, bro?
Please
You know, I need a laugh that lasts that long
I'm not gonna beat Renault like run a lot of whatever your name is
Rolana in five tries. I'm like, no, that's we already beat Renault
Is this too, oh who's ruin acquisition that's cool
America's ruin looks like a huge head or huge eye, why do I say head?
That's all
Wait, I thought I had more
Do I not
I thought I had like more frick
No now I have a hundred k rooms and I don't know what to do with them
It's over here. There's a couple of guys up to no good started making trouble in my neighborhood
I got one little fight and my mom got scared
She said
Hey
Can I not go this way
But then I would have to jump down
Uh-oh not resin
I
Just again, why do you have to be mad? It's just game
It's just arrow why you have to be mad
I
Die I missed all of them what
What how did one of them die I didn't hit them
Burb
I don't care about starlight shards. Give me cool armor. Oh almost fell
Who do we ask when we don't know what's way to go
Ever just exploded
Just thinks of uh
Shrek or Fiona singing
Mortis
Oh, no, how do I get back just kidding
Gravity gravity got me good
Fast mate who's next
Why does it take three hits to kill you should only take two
Burb
Why does there a bird explode over there
Another one died over there that doesn't make any sense to me
Don't tell me my runes are down there
Where are my runes?
Okay, I was gonna say
I was gonna say I sorry, I forgot that there was a gap here
Hello little fellas
Get out of the way. I'm gonna kill you little mouse
Just kidding. You know what you escaped with your life. You you you dodged me
You dodged me
Uh realistically I would slip off of these rocks in in a heartbeat
Oh, hello tortle. Hello tortle. Hello dog
Dog, what are you guys eating? There's nothing there. Oh, you're kind of eating some moss
Oh my god, so you gave me motion sick that's moving back
All right, we got a ladder
I like the waterfalls
What's in here? What's in here? What's in here? I'm trying to see if I can lock on anything in here
Not resin
It's not resin, I'll tell you that it's really cool because it looks like fire my lantern thermolite
Dog
It's not a little bit of a dog
All right
Time to climb
Hmm
You ain't give me a grace up here. Oh, I had feeling someone was gonna be around there
You're gonna knock me off aren't you? Yep. Goodbye my people need me
It's not resin
You're dinosaurs to tear
Does anybody else gonna jump out try to kill me? Oh what I can't open that to go back
Oh, yes, I can actually push
I always love me a good uh
That I would have to open that a lot more. I always like me a good uh walk back to do with the grace
Those are my favorite. They're really well laid out and right lies of pee
Oh
Enjoy the Deadpool movie. It was great. It was so good. It like blew all my expectations out of the water
I hope you enjoy it. Have a good one
All right
Oh
Mesmer's soldiers acts. Oh, am I gonna go kill mesmer?
I've seen mesmer's boss battle. It looks actually insane. So I hope that mesmer's not good by
That would be awkward. Ow. That was pretty good, bro
Did that really well
You're doing you doing it. You're doing it. Well, stop giving me freaking string actual string is
Point for draw string stuff, but I'm not really using that
I thought that was a ladder I could use it's not
Is there a dog over here that I just have something to cross?
Oh, I knew it. I knew it. I knew it. You're a bigger dog
I
Saw you coming one a mile away. I thought I saw it up here though, which is funny. Um, all right
I'm under the business. So this year is good
Oh, bro. What are you doing up here?
Yeah, the Deadpool movies are great
Yeah, I don't get that
I think people just don't like like if you're not
A like a fan of superhero movies
Oh my god
Oh
We're an aristocrat you're a risk to annoying
Boomi, are you laying on something I can't look I can't cast a spell
Oh, you're on my mouse. That's why
Boomi boomi. No, you sure it's making me attack for no reason
There we go
How'd you get up there my blood last time how'd you get up there, bro?
I can't do it
Muthril this won't do shit against you
Ha one hit one kill you look at the same we are wearing the same outfit
Yo, what's that guy carry a night rematch
If your Deadpool is you to pull he controls the galaxy
And he doesn't wish for people to die just his heart's better. They're bad and they're good. Give him a good ending. Oh
Oh
This uh, but like you superhero movies this is a marvel
Sorry, no, I don't think I finished my thought
I meant like if you don't know who Deadpool is like if you don't know he how how much he breaks
The uh, wait, I'm supposed to go all the way around again. How much he breaks the fourth wall
You're gonna think it's like they're explaining the movie
Wait what?
It'd be funny if there was like a time outer god that rewinds time
That one makes a lot of sense because they explain why you die like the game the dying mechanic, but imagine
Like explaining the why do they always respawn and ag re-aggro you like they never met you before a mechanic
Where are you dog?
I missed you you're gonna kill me dog aren't you?
There you are
Because time is also like all the other gods represents a form of death
So I was taking the making a piss in the bush here
Castle anxious castle anxious, I'm sorry
Pass y'all
I realized I lost my 100k runes, but that's fine. I just realized that
I'm not gonna bother with y'all
Okay, I need to kill the dog because like a dog follows me
The dogs always look so sickly
Boomi why is your mouth open? I can see your little teeth
Boomi your tooth is poking out
Keep your teeth in your mouth, sir
I
It's funny that their outfits are green to me
Okay
It's just a bazillion magic glint blades
Oh
Yeah
Is that the case facts bro
I can't believe they're using same rat and dog home models. Yeah, they're just recoloring them
They're all just skinny dogs
I don't get it. I don't know why they don't use like like the wolves or something just make them on fire
Or have like a green collar
It doesn't even let me lock on
Oh
So
This is where
Is this the top of the thingy oh, there's stuff over here
I think he just sounds a curious
Something tells me a graze is nearby
Does demon souls have rats it's a good question
Another she be in the matrix, what do you mean?
Well think about like how many enemies you come across in this game it makes sense that you kind of just want to
Reskin and just focus on the lore in the building
Ah, bitch
I'll kill the dog over here
Okay, who me I blame you because you got up and gotten the way and I couldn't see
Oh, I can't see past your head, but that's fine
Oh booby best cat debatable, I think he's gonna fall asleep on my mute button
So if I go quiet again, that is why because his head is nodding off right near the mute button
On my go XLR
So
The dog just randomly diagros over here, okay
Ah
Oh
He's gonna develop so confident
I probably should use a different weapon
But like I don't really have a weapon that I like and I want to use yet
So
No bad doggie
I
Was like really hoping I didn't aggro him, but I did
Not here I'm not here. Oh Jesus Christ
There's no point in doing that's not gonna do anything
I did like the backhand blades
Maybe I'll use those
Oh
Wait, I forget how there we go
I
Call that style point make them cold. Uh, I actually don't know what ash of war. It's not where I'm going
I don't know what ash of wars I have well, I took you for dead. I have your own
You
Quality
I can make it blood
Uh, I don't know if that's the case
What
Do I not have any freaking money? I don't
Yeah, I didn't have any money. Sorry I had to crush something in my hands
I
Sick
See you
And I can't do hand in here I'll try maybe I can I'm just
I
We just knocked off my wrist rest and he's laying on my mute button and I'm surprised it hasn't gone off yet
Let's finish dinner. Nice. What'd you eat?
Brother, let's go
I'm gonna test it on him
That's not what I wanted to do that's a stop let me kill you
I don't think this is gonna make enough damage
No, I don't want to go this way
Homie cheeseburger nice
The level are they they're level eight
I
Hate what the heck? I don't know if they're whispering or freaks me out. Ah
Dude the dog's gonna freaking kill me
I did not go down here
Yeah, never mind
I
Still I do like that sword a lot though. Um, I do have the
I don't really have anything that scales with I have a carrying a knight sword
And possibly could level that up
Oh, there's no point. I'd rather not. Why would I why would I why would I do that?
Why would I fight kill the carry and I with its own probably pretty bad? So, um
Yeah, I just don't have strength that's been so relaxed
Don't got a lot to work with people
I can't even use bloodhound thing
So
How did that arrow freaking get me
She
Oh my god
Oh
I'm tired of running up these freaking stairs dude
I might come back to him later because I just I cannot be asked to try to kill him right now
I'd rather go look for a closer side of grace
Cool or moonville for my dungeon. Yeah
I didn't know there were stairs there. So let me go down those stairs
I'm just avoid him completely because I've gotten everything I need over there
Okay
Up now I think it's right now still
I
Can I knock him off can I cheese him that way and knock him off?
Oh
Oh, is he gonna come down here?
Oh, just scared the absolute crap out of me. Oh my god that jump scared me so bad
I
Don't even get to get here what that guy said
I wanted to just get what the guy was
Oh
Wow firefly
I'm busy doing something right now
Oh my god
Healing run
I
Think there was more stuff over there, but it really just wanted grace
Just give me a grace I worship I just
See I knew I would have to fight this guy
Came in handy a little later
Don't let him get up here get along get out here
Oh, do you fall off that'd be great actually
Grace reach out and touch grace
Thank you
I
Here let's see here boss time who's over here
Oh
Who's in here?
Oh, it's uh
Oh
Can I
Get her sicker boy sicker. Oh her hair is black interesting because you don't see
You don't really see run all his hair
We're Lana and Ranala. Yeah, that's very but you know, there is gonna be some lady out there
That just really really really likes them
And we'll name them that
She literally has the same like moveset is
Melania
Bye-bye. See you. See you. Have a good night. Have a good time
Magic resistant. Yeah, that's why that's why I I'm really probably
Just gonna use try to get bleed bead build up on her. In fact, let me just like to hand it
That's not what I wanted to do hands
I
Really just panic rolling
What I didn't accidentally do that. All right, you know what?
I'm gonna make tears put it in work and I'm not really doing anything
What the hell she just totally dodged that I don't why I don't know why it's not let me chew hands
Oh, yeah, water I don't have any lightning stuff though
I did whole triangle in r1 and it's having me do this
It was weird I fixed it what's down here
Hello, oh that's where it came from
All right
I'm gonna get you
I'm gonna bleed build you up baby girl. How much did I level?
I didn't level this at all. I would be a heavy load if I did that anyways
No, she's even resisted a lot
No, you backed out her
I can't
Can't even break her boys
Oh
I I can't beat her because I need a better weapon. I'm actually gonna come back to her. I need a better weapon
That's not
the moon veil
She leaps in the shape of a crescent moon. Oh, that's actually pretty funny. All right
I'm actually quite tired. So I'm gonna end the stream here, but I'm gonna come back
And why did I unplug that and I am
Gonna find another weapon
I'll be honest. I might play a little of this by myself
I won't do like any of the major bosses, but I'll do um, I'm just probably gonna go like
Digger out of stuff by myself because it'll hard for me to not play this off stream
Yeah, yeah, I might do some like farming stuff
Um
But thank you for hanging out with me. Thank you for you know, we could be be chill and just hang and just chat and have a good time
Um, see we did one hour and then three hours of game
Aren't you happy and we beat a boss. We beat the dragon that I'm in the lion. Boomie. You look like something in your ear
um
Have fun with the mogwin ledge. What does that mean?
Hold on
There we go. Now I can be over here
Um, let's find someone to raid. I'm gonna I'm honestly probably gonna go to bed after I eat something because I'm just so tired
um
even even um
Although, I'm sure like I'll wake up in the middle of the night because of my gamer subs
I'll be like you're actually energized right now
um
Do me a fancy past you. Thank you for the mail
And you can just tell the person that I raid you can just call say maidenless raid
Ha ha ha
Maidenless raid
Redirect
Um
Are any of the girls streaming? No, okay
I
Didn't know if I was going to stream today or not. Uh, okay, I'm gonna raid
Momo
Monet
Okay
They just started wait, how long have they been streaming? They actually might be ending soon
Because they they've been streaming for as long as me just about hold on. Let me see
Okay, we'll we'll raid yay Yugi
um
Because she just started like an hour ago. Whereas Momo has been starting like playing for like five hours. So
We'll do that
Because I always feel bad I
Um, please don't attack my mouse right now. I'm trying to do stuff. I always feel bad like reading someone and they're like about to end
Because like I always like want to stream longer with someone raids me. So it's like, you know, taking advantage of the raid
Let me get back to you there we go
All right
I'll see you guys
She's mid game. Oh, okay
Oh, okay, she's made so she's like, I'm sorry. I don't know who to choose. They're both amazing
Is there a soon? Yeah, but is there isn't 30 minutes and I'm I'm too tired to stay for 30 minutes
Madam once raid
She's
Okay, then I'm gonna go back to momo then
Because I haven't raided momo yet. I don't know yet. I was gonna call her momo
I think I've raided
All right, you can just say made the most raid
Bye have a good night everybody. Thank you for stopping by. Um, we have the asmr tomorrow
I will be
role playing will be
British accent. It will be reverb and echo. So
Yeah, um, it'll be
Well, it'll be I'll have to think of I'm still thinking of like the triggers and stuff
I don't know
I'll figure it out. I won't be at most. I might just be a lot of whispering to be honest with you
and like
Probably like reading you bible stories
Um, but we'll see we'll see
Unless she be is some more I'll just put you in the book of genesis the entire time
Yeah, I'm gonna go eat and watch an episode of the last kingdom and then pass out
And also see if fia is hungry. She ate a lot this morning. So she's she's big chilling
Which bible stories? I don't know probably the most horrible ones
Like Sodom and Gomorrah
Um, but yeah, we'll see we'll see and then like I might just like again like role playing
Let's do a lot of like unintelligible whispers. I'll just speak in tongues at you
All right, tell mo mo no. I said hi
Have a good time guys. I'm just gonna end it. I'm not bothering with the beginning and ending screen
I will actually know how to do a beginning screen because I have to do a few things. Um, but later. Bye